in switzerland on the coast of lake
geneva sits the quiet town of montreal
it was a place where people went to
retire to lots of lots of tea shops and
little old ladies kind of place but on
december 4th 1971
a giant fire at the local concert hall
took hold
eventually leading this man my name is
roger glover i'm the bass player of deep
purple
to help write this song
so let's rewind a bit
deep purple just arrived in switzerland
planning to record their next album
machine head at a local concert venue
but they couldn't start until frank
zappa and the mothers of invention
finished their show that afternoon being
big fans we went to the matinee show
and watched the mothers of invention in
frank about an hour or so into the show
someone had fired a flare gun into the
ceiling
the concert abruptly ended and once
everyone exited safely within five
minutes
flames everywhere and it raged it was
just a massive fire and went on
in fact it went on through the night
the concert hall was reduced to ashes
deep purple eventually found a new space
and feverishly recorded their sixth
studio album there was one problem
though we realized that we were a song
short so the band improvised and had an
idea why don't we write a song about
what happened to us here in montreux the
whole adventure of trying to make a
record and a place burning down
just then roger remembered a vision he
had back in montreal about
a day or two after the fire i woke up
one morning with the with four words
that i'd apparently said out loud they
seemed to be hanging in the room as i
opened my eyes
i kind of said to myself what did i just
say
smoke on the water or something like
that
smoke in the water well that could be
the story of the fire and so we sat down
and literally wrote the words to it in
probably about 15 minutes
smoke on the water
fire in the sky
the song became a surprise hit for the
band but also taught roger a valuable
lesson you're at your best when you're
not trying too hard
i think you have more fun when you when
you don't know that anything's going to
come of it
you